ارى هذا المشهد مره واحده على الاقل من كل
شهر فلن يغطي ابو ابراهيم احتياجاته
واستخداماته من الماء سنوات وابو ابراهيم
يعتمد على شراء الماء بعد انقطاعات باتت
شبه طبيعيه حاله كحالي معظم الاردنيين
الذين يخشون مشهد خزانات المياه الفارغه
في فصل الصيف
النهائيه في فصل الشتاء بتصل قليل يعني في
الشهر او شهر ونص مره وما بتكفي احتياجات
المنزل ومعنا كثير كثير يعني فقر مائي مش
معنا
اصلا تراجعا كبيرا في مستوى الهطول المطري
وما بين عوامل طبيعيه واخرى سياسيه اهمها
غياب العداله اقليميا في توزيع المياه فمن
سد الوحده مع سوريا الى مياه نهر الاردن
مع اسرائيل سجلت السنوات الماضيه
عن كبيرا بضخ المياه ومع زياده اعداد
السكان في الاردن لاضافه لازمات اللجوء
بات المواطن الاردني يعيش ضمن خط الفقر
المائي
بشكل كبير خلال السنوات الماضيه حيث انه
كان التدفق عام 87 300 متر مكعب بالثانيه
في نهر اليرموك الان نتحدث عن اقل من متر
مكعب في الثانيه ونهار الاردن كان التدفق
في هذا النهر سنويا يزيد عن 750 مليون متر
مكعب الان نتحدث عن 30 الى 40 مليون متر
مكعب وجوديه في الاردن حذر منها البنك
الدولي بسبب شح المياه تضاف لتصنيفه كساني
افقر دوله مائيا في العالم وفي ظل البحث
عن حلول تتعرقل بسبب الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
ومشاريع مائيه مع وقف التنفيذ تقف الحكومه
امام تحدي كبير ينعكس على المواطنين في
بحثه عن الماء سهى جميل العربي عمان